that's it hi this is David P from the
Boston Bruins I'm Alex toink of the
Detroit Red Wings I'm Nick Suzuki from
the Montreal Canadians I'm Tom Wilson of
the Washington Capitals I'm kale marar of the
Colorado Avalanche I'm Travis conne with the
Philadelphia Flyers I'm William neander
of the Toronto M police warer from the
Toronto police break a truck of the Ottawa
centers this is min shop ministick hardest
shop some bad Curves in here first thing of
the morning I'm just trying to rip it as hard
as I can are you doing a backhanded shot I
don't know what I'm doing it's too early I
got to warm up you know I play mini sticks
quite a bit with my son so it should work
[Music] out these things pop up
quick BR Noe that's a bad
one it's got to be the ball
not even close okay just
keep it low Jesus that is not
low yes got 53 I think I'm pretty
proud of that stick help me
out all right felt like it was going to
break so we might need to get a couple more
in that was a rocket I'll take the
the 53 it's respectable halfway to
100 with the mini stick uh I'll take
it 50 oh oh okay that might be the
way that could be it uh we'll take
the 51 and we'll be happy with the
results I think the performance went pretty
well as far as I heard I tied the the lead
and then I uh broke a ball as well all
right there you go 51 I'll take it I
mean I'm tired with a couple of guys so I think
probably the bigger guys going to win this one
though I think I shot it too hard so
it didn't register that's how good I
was no not my best performance didn't
work out the way I I expected it to
so it was good it was fun but uh yeah I got to be
better that's it I gave it my
all I left it all out there uh put the
whole body into it and uh as a result uh I'm
[Applause]
leader
for